pourquoi mathieu à une fois en booking
je suis arrivé en bout qing et tong ont
fini à 4 heures du matin tout ça ouais
et je suis rentré dans la chambre
d'hôtel et il y avait un jeune garçon de
nuit et tout ça je ne sais pas du tout
comment évidemment il est rentré et
aucune idée alors j'imagine wc du lycée
descartes dont qu'il ait dû connaître le
bas le garba pouvoir impasse royal en
est donc qui s'est passé qu'est ce que
pour la gauche ensemble
mais non j'ai passé j'étais halluciné je
vois la porte donc je pensais que
quelqu'un de très haut mais j'ai bien vu
que non c'est un gamin en fait c était
très jeune ça eh ben j'ai rien je lui
dis de sortir est de partir mais est-ce
que je peux rester je t'aime beaucoup
sont en photo n'a pas d'iphone aux
bretons comme l on veut 4h du mat
mais alors où quelqu'un dans votre
chambre bah alors qu'il avait il ya même
avec quelqu'un déjà énervé les terres en
civil étaient puma qui ira du tournoi
qu'il est arrivé un truc de ouf
ah ouais ça mais quelqu'un qui me suit
guy m'a suivi pendant trois ans sur les
réseaux sociaux
ouais et un jour qui sonne directement
m'apporte faut juste quatre codes 1.44
contador avait habité la bnp
[Rires]
je crois que c'est mon gardien je
regarde j'ai axé mon gardien et
finalement je ne suis pas du tout
physionomiste j'ouvre la porte je leur
accès quelqu un quelque chose
d'important et la personne me dit oui je
suis telle personne est le nom je m'en
souviens parce que j'ai reçu des
courriers etc
mais alors j'ai hurlé j'ai fermé la
porte en sud-gironde ouvert lapin et je
vais pousser et tout n'était avec un
mois vous avez ouvert mais vous alors
très intéressantes comme question
l'appliquait me dire le moins
intéressant ah oui abc là on sent quand
on a peur tout peut arriver et donc va
dire je vous jure j'ai mis tellement pas
ah ouais quand j'ai rouvert la porte
mais mais mais tout pouvait arriver là
et parlant total avec quoi bein garde à
vue un élan garde à vue et là il
recommence un peu donc large et manu au
procureur de la république a pris tout
ça oui ben venir chez soit à un enfant
etc
c'est ben tu swiss est dangereux quoi en
plus ils baisser son pantalon malawi
ah non mais tu sais pas ce qui arrive
quoi ils baisser leur pantalon
et aujourd'hui comme un truc bizarre le
gardien quand il tape trop jeune je
venais à christine kelly
c'est le coin pourtant à la pente
[Rires]
bravo